it's hard to believe there's only one
episode of Silo left this season but
fear not Silo dwellers Apple has renewed
Silo for a second season but there's
still a lot of mystery remaining as the
pressure to find Juliet Mounds in this
video we'll be taking a deep dive into
the down deep uncovering all its
Mysteries with new theories and clues I
haven't read the books so there won't be
any book spoilers so everything in here
is based purely off sleuthing I've left
time stamps below so you can see all the
topics I'll be covering Now put on your
suits it's time to clean last episode we
saw Juliet seemingly plummet to her
death in her attempt to escape Sims in
judicial luckily Juliet noticed Paul
showing signs of the syndrome and used
this to her advantage to escape while
simultaneously snagging the bag that
contained the hard drive and in this
episode we see that she lands a few
levels below with the entire Silo
basically after her she goes to the one
place Sims would least suspect his
family's apartment and this makes sense
because only a few computers in the Sun
Milo have the ability to read a cis-off
protected drives normally she'd be able
to access this drive from her Sheriff's
terminal but that's obviously out of the
question which leaves either Bernard
Meadows or sims's computer as an
alternative holding sims's wife Camille
and son Anthony hostage Juliet connects
the drive to the computer unaware that
its connection would alert the Watchers
to her location this will give her
limited time before having to flee yet
again but there's another problem the
drive requires a password and luckily
Allison all the way back from season one
cracked it we'll see this paper with a
bunch of failed attempts crossed out and
some of these include history Meadows
and poison there's also this cryptic
line on the bottom right that reads what
was taken what we took who is we and who
are the takers who came the password
however is the word Library circled here
the word can also be seen etched into
the very drive itself and the contents
of the drive are very much like a
library containing hundreds of documents
some of these in include critical
medical and power supply inventories and
a blueprint of The Silo itself which
George found in episode 1. luckily
George has left Juliet a file named
start here which includes a video he
made using the camcorder found in
episode 2 but before Juliet can fully
sink her teeth into this video she is
worn by Camille that judicial will be on
its way and Camille had every
opportunity to either kill Juliet or
wait for judicial to come and arrest her
why did she let Juliet go the answer she
tells Sims is that she knows what would
have happened if the Raiders came they
would have killed her Camille was a
Raider for 12 years before moving to it
and seems to be wary of them not letting
her husband's escort check her apartment
Camille also owns a firearm which is
only reserved for a certain Personnel
but it's never mentioned if this is her
husband's luckily Juliet has a friend in
Patrick Kennedy she saved his life a few
episodes ago when Sims and Trumbull
tried to frame him for the murders of
mar Barnes and mayor Ruth he's contacted
a hacker by the name of Danny who seems
to have aided in the disruption of the
Watcher's security cameras to Aid in
Juliet's Escape Dany is a part of a ring
that hacks The Silo security network and
perhaps he can unlock the hard drive on
a non-sys op authorized computer in fact
Dany once owned this hard drive but
didn't have the password thus he sold it
to Regina George's ex who then gave it
to George Danny can also spoof the
drive's location making the Watchers
believe it's being accessed somewhere
else than where it really is while at
Patrick's Juliet can take the time she
really needs to see George's video and
George is pretty candid telling her that
his main plan was to use her to gain
knowledge about The Silo then leave her
behind but he ended up falling in love
at Cooper's Shadow party in episode 2 he
was going to tell her that he had found
what he was looking for back in episode
1 he saw on the hard drive a blueprint
which showed some sort of tunnel below
the giant pit of water in the sealed off
section of the silo there is apparently
some sort of 15-foot High door that he's
found that likely connects to this but
he's been unable to get through it then
there's the added problem of the water
something Juliet was unable to overcome
he says quote it was nothing to worry
about now there are a lot of questions
spinning through my head first is this
door under the water or somewhere off to
the side second is the water itself when
he says it's not a problem what is he
referring to could it be that the water
looks super deep but it's actually just
a foot or two that there is some way to
remove the water or that the water
itself is safe to Traverse maybe the
water isn't a barrier to this door at
all now Juliet is an engineer so I
wonder if her skills can be used to get
this mystery door open George also
mentions that the people of The Silo
deserve to know the truth and why
Allison Becker went out to clean and she
can start by checking out the file
called Jane Carmody cleaning we first
saw this file way back in episode 1 and
there's also mention of this cleaning in
the mayor's ledgers that Ruth was going
through shortly before her death the
video would have us believe that the
cafeteria screens are a lot that the
outside is beautiful and filled with
life as evidenced by this flock of birds
but here's what's really interesting
Holston saw this same group of birds
when he went out to clean this would
imply that his suit also has some sort
of screen of playing this video I
personally think these images from
holston's point of view look computer
generated they also don't show the dead
bodies of previous cleaners so what's
real the Jane Carmody file or the
cafeteria screen could both be
manipulated the very fact that a Jane
Carmody video exists implies that
someone was recording her that the suit
itself contains a recording device all
of this is making my mind explode and
before we continue if you're liking
these videos be sure to like And
subscribe I'll be coming out with my
season one finale video as soon as the
episode airs last episode we talked
about this idea of a new Rebellion for
Juliet to survive she'll either need to
find a new way out note like this tunnel
or lead some sort of Uprising against
the powers that be last episode we saw a
number of shots from other Silo dwellers
looking on as judicial overstep their
bounds we have this father and son who
witnessed Juliet getting beaten and also
this Raider who may have seen Sims and
Bernard falsely claim that Juliet asked
to go out to clean her name is Gene
Robinson and was one of Paul's former
students at the beginning of this
episode we'll see how other Silo
dwellers watch on concerned as Sims
searches for Juliet the show is really
making an effort to show us how the
regular folks of the silo are taking in
judicials over steps with Paul's wife
stating that there are Rumblings of
rebellion among the people I think this
is One Direction the Story could take if
you've watched my trailer slew thing
you'll know I've been very curious when
this device would show up for now I'm
just gonna call it a fob it has the
number 18 on it which is the same number
found on the hard drive as far as we
know Bernard is the only one who
possesses one of these and it links red
while he's talking to Sims either this
is some sort of key or perhaps a pager
it does make a buzzing sound while on
his desk almost as if someone wants his
attention or it's alerting him to Danger
later on the episode we'll see the red
light has turned off as far as the
number 18 goes the only Theory I
currently have is that 18 is the number
of their Silo meaning there could be
multiple silos Paul's had one hell of a
day in this episode from being walloped
by the syndrome to discovering amazing
things about Georgia even though Paul's
wife wants him to go back to judicial
where it's safe Paul needs to prove
himself vowing to make things right by
catching Juliet and this journey ends up
shattering everything he knows about the
silo while searching Juliet's apartment
he sees A Shard of one-way glass used by
the cameras to spy on the citizens in
the bathroom he finds where Juliet has
stashed the book about Georgia and it's
here he's really faced with a crisis of
Faith his entire life has been about
following The Pact but all this new
information is teaching him it was all
along this is why he puts the book in
the oven just get rid of it and pretend
he never saw it but something within him
compels him to rip out a page before he
does this Paul being done with the pact
is emphasized when he puts his copy away
we get one more interesting bit of
information when Sim questions Juliet's
father about her whereabouts Dr Nichols
recounts the story of Hannah's suicide
stating that the railing on the first
level is worn smooth from all the people
gripping it tightly before jumping over
this is how Hannah killed herself I'm
not entirely convinced that Hannah did
kill herself and I could see a world
where Foul Play was involved their
conversation also brings up this idea of
what is more important your family or
The Silo was Sims stating that no one
person is more important than the ten
thousand but Sims is a hypocrite he'll
later expend valuable resources by
having Raiders escort his wife and child
when they could have been out looking
for Juliet when Bernard hears about this
it makes him question whether Sims
should even be considered to be his
Shadow this is apparently what Sims has
been striving for to become Bernard's
Shadow and eventually the de facto
leader of the silo later in the episode
seems his wife says quote we have one
goal one ambition which could mean the
two of them ruling the silo or it could
mean something even more nefarious after
this convo Sims makes his way back down
to the Watchers and look at what he sees
on the screen for a brief moment there
are the words audio display Silo level
17 the floor Sims lives on and some
audio data being archived it makes me
wonder if Bernard was listening in to
sims's conversation with his wife and if
he was he'll know that Camille let
Juliet free and this could get her sent
out to clean now we get our trailer
sleuthing section of the video so if you
don't want to see any clips that we can
expect next episode turn away now but
don't worry there's only about two of
them here's amundsen Sims The Shadow
accompanied by Raiders in what appears
to be a raid on Patrick Kennedy's
apartment we last Saw Emerson taking
Lucas away so maybe this info came from
him there's this shot of Bernard
reciting the lines a mayor or Sheriff
says when taking someone out to clean if
Bernard was listening to Camille's
conversation with Sims my guess is that
it's her who's going to be sent out
other than that it could be Juliet or
any of her accomplices including Lucas
Patrick or Danny that's it for this
episode of Silo let me know what your
thoughts and theories are in the
comments below make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
what the actual [__]
foreign